>> Will Sentance: Trước khi chúng ta làm điều đó, vấn đề của việc này là gì?
Không vấn đề gì.
Có một cách tiếp cận trực quan tuyệt vời khi chúng ta hiểu rõ
nó hoạt động như thế nào.
Dữ liệu phản hồi, nó chỉ có sẵn trong chức năng gọi lại.
Chúng tôi không thấy điều này ở đây, chúng tôi sẽ thấy nó trong giây lát.
Mọi dữ liệu quay lại từ các tính năng của trình duyệt web của chúng tôi đều hoạt động.
Ví dụ, tôi đi và nhận một số tweet từ Twitter.
Chúng sẽ được phân tích cú pháp làm đối số của hàm
đã được thiết lập để chạy khi hoàn thành.
Điều đó có thể trở nên khá phức tạp,
bởi vì dữ liệu sẽ chỉ có sẵn bên trong đây.
Điều đó có thể trở nên khá lộn xộn.
Và có thể cảm thấy kỳ lạ khi nghĩ rằng phân tích một hàm thành một hàm khác,
chỉ để nó chạy nhiều hơn sau đó.
Có lẽ nó cảm thấy kỳ lạ?
Nó chắc chắn cảm thấy kỳ lạ.
Khi tôi thấy điều đó, setTimeout (printHello, 0),
mọi thứ cho tôi biết rằng tôi phải chạy printHello bằng cách nào đó bên trong setTimeout.
Mọi thứ cho tôi biết điều đó.
Đặc biệt nếu nó cho biết 0 mili giây.
Tuy nhiên, tôi hoàn toàn không.
Tôi đang chuyển một định nghĩa hàm vào, chỉ dành cho
nó được gọi ra ngoài tầm kiểm soát của tôi.
Rất nhiều sau này trong ứng dụng.
Mất quyền kiểm soát việc thực hiện và xác định điều gì đó của chúng tôi,
printHello riêng điều đó sẽ [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC] Chà, không phải tùy tiện đâu, nhưng
ngoài tầm kiểm soát đó sẽ được gọi?
Muộn màng.
Khi chúng ta viết mã, chúng ta nghĩ về nó ít nhất là,
Tôi đang kiểm soát cấu trúc mã của mình.
Nhưng thay vào đó, tôi sẽ để lại một phần hoàn toàn nằm ngoài tầm kiểm soát của tôi sau này.
Đó là một cảm giác kỳ lạ.
Tôi sẽ nói điều này, khi bạn đã hiểu rõ về cách nó hoạt động.
nó thực sự không quá tệ.
Nếu bạn không hiểu nó hoạt động như thế nào thì thật là kinh khủng.
Nhưng nếu bạn hiểu rõ cách nó hoạt động,
bạn biết rằng đây là một hàm giả vờ trong JavaScript.
Đó là một mặt tiền.
Đối với chức năng trong nền.
Bạn biết rằng hàm này sẽ được chuyển vào hàng đợi và
sau đó được phép quay trở lại JavaScript, vâng, ngoài tầm kiểm soát của bạn, nhưng
đó là toàn bộ bản chất của lập trình không đồng bộ.
Bạn thực hiện một chuỗi duy nhất là gửi các tác vụ và
bạn đưa chúng trở lại tự động, sẵn sàng sử dụng trong chức năng hoặc
giá trị trả về hoặc giá trị phản hồi của chúng.
Sẵn sàng sử dụng trong chức năng mà bạn đã thiết lập trước đó để được gọi sau này.
Bạn hiểu rằng chính mô hình kiến ​​trúc đầu vào, đầu ra không đồng bộ.
Bạn hiểu rằng đó là thiết kế.
Nhưng tôi hiểu nó không trực quan.
Lợi ích, siêu rõ ràng khi bạn hiểu cách hoạt động của nó.
Chức năng bạn phân tích cú pháp sẽ được tự động kích hoạt.
Sau khi hoàn thành tính năng của trình duyệt Web, quay trở lại JavaScript, và sau đó được gọi
khi trình duyệt Web kết thúc công việc hoặc tính năng của trình duyệt Web kết thúc công việc.